what kind of stuff were you doing in the
lean years in New York I mean I was I
feel like I had every job um I I mean I
I have to say like I should have said
this at the top I am a very big fan of
the show you guys oh but I've been
watching since like the early days thank
you that when I was just a little baby
yeah not I was like okay we got it we're
very old I really appreciate it that's
nice and I used to I used to before DVR
there was a thing called VCR and I would
tape it and watch the next day because I
was like a big comedy nerd and this was
like my favorite weird show oh thank you
yeah so weirdly when I was doing all
these jobs in New York I feel like you
sort of followed me around to each job
now you don't know this but I was a
waitress out of restaurant in New York
that you would go to I worked at the did
you ever wait on me I was like the
hostess so I hostess to you right right
and you were guys please tell me I
didn't slap you on the button say that
but Milwaukee's
[Applause]
this come you can be did you do it that
is so Richter yeah
it'll lay down the law and then I was
like the receptionist at a design firm
where you and your wife were getting
your house designed Wow and and you know
like I babysat for a place where you
took your kids to pianos and so either
I'm just I just kept walking into your
life yes and do we ever talk or hang out
you know we didn't hang out yeah you
would remember I'm very cool
[Laughter]
yeah yeah I remember yeah but he's very
shallow yeah thank you
yeah no you were always very nice and
very Conan II you know what I mean what
does Conan EMU
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it is funny how people that know me I
will say you are the exact new there's a
lot of performers that are this way on
TV and then there's someone else when
they go I am this person 24 hours a day
it's a sickness but I'm sure if I ran
into you at a design place or wherever
we were a dentist's office I'm the
person that's out there going like hey
we kind of had like a chat and then you
walked out I was like cool that was
Conan and then right before you left you
like poked your head back in and you
were like
where's charm what you describing now
neurological tick was your burgess
Meredith
you